Probably not, although anecdotal evidence
shows it has a strong correlation with stupidity.
What it may do is cause vomiting, vertigo,
confusion, drowsiness, breathing difficulties,
burning in the esophagus, sore throat, weakness,
and diarrhea, even when ingested in small
amounts; in larger portions, it can cause
loss of consciousness, internal hemorrhaging,
convulsions and death (from circulatory failure
and/or damage to vital organs).
To address the question at hand a little more
specifically, although vision loss is a potential
symptom of gasoline poisoning, complete vision
loss doesn’t appear to be a common consequence
for those who ingest it, unlike many of the
aforementioned symptoms.
Although, you will experience complete vision
loss when you die.
So, in that sense- yes, drinking gasoline
can cause you to go permanently blind.
And just for reference, it doesn’t take
much swallowed gasoline to kill you- just
half an ounce can cause severe intoxication
for adults and even death for small children.
A 12 ounce drink of gasoline will often be
fatal to most humans.
Despite these dangers, however, a brave few
have overcome their (rational) fear of gasoline’s
toxicity and, instead, developed a powerful
addiction to petrol.
In 2011, it was reported that 71-year-old
Chen Dejun, of Chongqing, China, has been
drinking gasoline for over 40 years.
According to one report, in 1969 when Chen
picked up his habit (based on a folk remedy),
kerosene was the elixir of choice; adapting
to the times, he later switched to gasoline,
and in 2011, he was supposedly imbibing nearly
one gallon each month (about 4 ounces per
day).
A couple of years earlier, it was reported
that a 14-year-old boy from the Sichuan province
in China was struggling with a 5-year habit.
Born from a desire to turn into a Transformer,
the boy’s addiction began with drinking
the butane out of cigarette lighters, but
soon progressed into siphoning gasoline from
the family’s motorcycle and sipping on that.
Although the boy’s parents state that his
habit is up to nearly 3 quarts a day, experts
highly doubt that claim.
Regardless of the amount, the addiction has
had a devastating effect on the child who,
before the habit, was “a very smart boy,”
but now “he doesn’t [even] know seven
plus 17.”
In 2012, one episode of TLC’s My Strange
Addiction told the story of 20-year-old Shannon
who drank up to two ounces each day.
Describing the flavor as “sweet and sour,
like a tangy sauce,” Shannon also noted
that although it burns the back of her throat,
it also “makes me feel good.”
More recently, a 45-year old UK man, Brian
Taylor, was arrested for drinking petrol despite
the fact that he was under an anti-social
behavior order (ASBO) prohibiting him from
going near gasoline pumps.
Apparently, his first gasoline-related run-in
with the authorities happened in 2005, when
he was found to have stolen fuel 51 times,
to drink, after which, “bug-eyed and ruddy
faced,” he would dance “a little jig while
high on
the fumes.”
Of course, not everyone who drinks gasoline
does it on purpose, although that doesn’t
mean they don’t pay a heavy price.
In February 2012, 43-year-old, Gary Allen
Banning of Havelock, North Carolina, accidentally
drank a bit of gasoline when he mistook a
jar of liquid that was sitting out on his
friend’s counter for a palatable beverage.
Wisely, he immediately spit it out before
much was ingested.
Unwisely, sometime later that evening, he
went outside, stuck a cigarette in his mouth
and attempted to light it, at which point
he burst into flames.
You see, he hadn’t changed his shirt and
had spilled the gasoline all over it after
his swig.
Medics rushed him to the hospital and later
to the UNC Burn Center, but due to the severity
of the burns, he died early the next day.
For his valiant effort to protect humanity’s
collective gene pool by sacrificing his life,
Gary Allen Banning was nominated for a Darwin
Award in 2012.
Methanol, like gasoline, is also highly toxic,
as one of Gary’s fellow nominees in 2012
discovered.
Employed as a truck washer for a Canadian
liquor store chain, the nominee (hereinafter,
Vodka Bob) had developed a bad habit of stealing
the hooch hidden by truck drivers in the cabs
of their vehicles.
On the fateful day, he discovered a vodka
bottle, although it was filled with a light
blue liquid.
Somehow forgetting that windshield washer
fluid is also blue (and often stored in vehicles),
Vodka Bob began swigging the toxic liquid.
Seemingly, he never realized that the wiper
fluid was not intended for human consumption
because he kept ingesting it for the next
two days.
Ultimately “he died in the hospital from
methanol poisoning.”
Weirder still, the 2007 Darwin Award winner
was Texas Mike, an alcoholic who preferred
rectal drinking, i.e., giving himself alcohol
enemas.
On the eve of his death, Mike poured more
than 100 ounces of sherry “right up the
old address.”
A significant amount to imbibe over a long
period of time, when taken all at once it
caused Mike to pass out; however, because
it was all still resting in his intestines,
his body continued to absorb it.
Consequently, he died from alcohol poisoning
with a blood alcohol content of 0.47% (in
many states, at .08% you are considered legally
drunk).
In response to this tragic story, the Darwin
Awards’ kindly readers posted many words
of sympathy including “takes shit-faced
to a whole new level,” “drunk off my ass,”
“rectum?
Hell no it killed him,” “up the hatch,”
and “a drop never touched his lips.”
And if you’re wondering, this same type
of thing is why vaporized alcohol inhalation
can be extremely dangerous.